washington journal continues
neil irwin is at our table this morning
he had this piece in the washington post
on february 16th
consumers paying debt saving more let me
just read the lead
paragraph here the recession that just
rocked the u.s economy happened in part
because americans were borrowing and
spending more
than they could afford now three years
after the downturn began
families are moving faster than many
analysts had expected
to put their finances in order by by
paying down debt and boosting
their savings how fast are americans
moving uh
people are getting there probably not as
far as people need to be in terms of
increasing savings rates in terms of uh
paying down credit card debt mortgage
debt that sort of thing but uh but
there's real progress there's real
measurable progress so the savings rate
is
over five percent that's not as high as
it was in the 80s but it is as high as
it was in the 90s remember right before
the uh the downturn the savings rate got
as low as one two percent uh for for a
good part of the 2000s
so savings rate is back up might go
higher but it's uh but it's
it's a lot higher than it was a couple
years ago could it ever return to the
80s
and uh where does it need to be for
analysts to say that we're in good shape
you know the
the thing is uh nobody really knows
there's there's no certainty of where
it's going to settle and where we end up
uh what is kind of the new normal in
terms of savings and debt levels and
that sort of thing
what we do know is that as we made a lot
of progress compared to
three years ago uh if if uh if we are
going to go back to the 1980s levels of
of saving seven percent instead of five
percent
that actually is bad news for the
economy over the near term over the next
couple years because it means that
people will be increasing their savings
rather than spending that money less
spending means
uh less jobs less of less of everything
so
you know part of the reason the economy
has been so bad the last couple years
has been so few jobs created
is that uh is that people have been
doing this kind of adjustment of their
household balance sheets and
uh the sooner they're done the sooner
the economy can actually improve so what
does it mean
this current saving trend what does that
mean for the the state of our economy
today
you know i talked to for the story a lot
of people who look at consumer debt
levels and and
consumer balance sheets pretty carefully
their their intuition their hunch is
that uh
we're about halfway through this we
might have another year of consumers
readjusting paying down debts
uh trying to get their finances in line
when they're done whether it's one year
from now or longer than that
uh that sets the stage for a much
stronger kind of growth in the in the
years ahead because
you know again every dollar you're not
saving you're uh you're not every dollar
you're
you're saving you're not spending and so
uh once household balance sheets are
back to normal then we can actually have
a full throated strong expansion instead
of this kind of weak
uh very slow expansion we've had the
last couple years you wrote in the piece
that there are three factors
involved can you tell us what those
factors are sure it's not just people
paying down debt so the best kind of uh
of of adjustment is people have a big
credit card bill they
uh the credit card balance they pay it
down they chip away at it over time
then at the end of the process they
they've wiped it out or they have a lot
less debt that they
they have to bear that's uh that's pure
good news for the economy another factor
is uh
people uh have defaulted on their loans
so if the bank says you know we don't
think we're ever going to get paid back
for this
uh this consumer isn't paying their
bills we're going to write it down
uh you know that's that's it reduces the
total amount of debt level that's out
there but what it doesn't do
is uh create a new situation where
people can spend if you weren't able to
pay your
credit card bill pay your mortgage
you're probably not going to drive the
economy going forward
a final aspect is uh is a just a simpler
aspect of you know these
uh these loans run off and and get paid
over you know they mature over time
let me show our viewers some of these
charts that were included in your story
consumer debt
quarterly and trillions it shows that
the percentage change
from the second quarter of 2008 to the
third quarter of 2010 you can see a
decline when it comes to mortgage debt
of about seven percent a decline when it
comes to
credit card debt of 14 percent auto
loans uh down about 12
but student loans up about 18 percent
yeah student loans that's the one uh the
one dark spot in this story
uh as you say other kinds of consumer
debt are down a lot
uh student debt you know people gone
back to school tuition prices have kept
rising uh people have had less income so
they needed to borrow more money for
school as opposed to using their current
income
those are all reasons student loan debt
seems to be rising you refer to in the
story
uh a study done by the federal reserve
of new york and they looked at whether
consumers are really paying down the
debt or just defaulting what what did
they find out
there is definitely some defaulting
going on which again is not uh not good
news for the long term because if you're
not able to pay your mortgage you're not
able to drive drive the economy going
forward
but uh the the good news is there is
more than that and there is genuine uh
people paying down debt and uh you know
a bunch of different kind of analysis
shows that there is some real progress
made not just uh not just defaults
so when people are defaulting i mean
obviously the impact on the economy is
what
well uh so it hurts bank balance sheets
so if you're a bank or if you're a
lender and
uh suddenly you're having to write down
loans that reduces your capital that
uh might make you less able to to lend
to other people uh it also
uh you know the good news is there's
less of a debt overhang for that
individual
the bad news is the reason there's a
less of a debt overhang is because they
weren't paying their bill so presumably
they don't have a job or they don't have
an income in some way that
doesn't make them likely to to be a real
uh economic growth engine
let's go to phone calls steve is a
republican in scranton pennsylvania
we're talking about americans
increasing their savings and whittling
down debt go ahead
good morning how you doing today morning
pleasure to talk to you
what uh what i find amazing is they tell
americans safe safe save and then on the
other hand they're telling them consume
consume
uh we're not producing anything anymore
because we're told go to college spend
sixty thousand go into debt
and don't become anything then once
you're in the working place
they want you to take all your money and
put it into a 401k
that magically disappears overnight if
the markets fluctuate
people need to invest in themselves get
creative
create their own business and produce
and that's how america will flourish
neil irwin uh that's right of course and
and uh
you know production is when you're uh
when you have a job what you're
fundamentally doing is you're producing
and making things
the thing is uh if you're going to make
things you need somebody else to buy it
you need somebody else to consume it so
every uh
you know the flip side of output is
consumption you need to consume to have
uh
to have investments so uh the sooner we
get through with this process of people
paying down debts and
uh and and uh getting their savings
rates to a sustainable level
the sooner they can actually start
consuming again which gives more
opportunities to people starting a
business or
uh looking to expand looking to invest
uh and that's uh you know you need both
sides of the coin for uh for an economy
to get moving
you study the job numbers when they come
out every
friday at 8 30 or thursday at 8 30. and
talk to that caller who just talked
about we don't produce anything
what sectors do you see an increase in
where are the jobs
uh you know we've seen some nice
momentum of all things in manufacturing
the last uh the last year or so what
happened the the manufacturing sector
was in this deep dive during the
recession
uh we've seen auto production come back
we've seen uh you know all kinds of
durable goods manufactured goods uh have
had some real momentum so you know it's
it's people like say america doesn't
make anything anymore that's really not
true we make a lot of stuff now we do it
with fewer people than was the case
uh five or ten years ago but uh but
manufacturing output is actually doing
okay
greensboro north carolina jimmy
independent caller go ahead
good morning guys how you all today good
morning uh
as far as increasing my savings i can't
say that i have done that
i'm too busy paying all my bills which
is really what i want to be doing
i want to be paying my bills and as far
as savings
goes i mean i've got a minimum amount
saved
because i'm productive you know i can go
out and work
so as long as i'm able to do that
i don't really see the need to save well
jimmy have you made it a
more of a priority in recent years to
pay down your debts to pay your bills
that's always been my priority okay not
more or less
now or uh you know earlier
but that's always been my priority
because i've always had
some form of debt whether it's car
payment house payment
you know whatever okay and i've got to
go out work in order to pay those debts
all right well c-span junkie tweets in
this when we save
u.s dollars we receive one percent
interest
thanks to the federal reserve and food
and energy rises two to five percent
our savings buy less at end why save
uh so that's true there's there's uh
essentially a zero
or even a slightly negative real rate
meaning an uh inflation adjusted
uh rate of return on most bank deposits
uh very safe investments
now people who've invested in in other
forms of uh
savings uh kind of long-term savings the
stock market things the stock market
uh riskier assets they've actually
gotten some decent returns last
uh interest rates are very low so uh if
there's even a little bit of inflation
suddenly you're losing money in in real
terms
uh if you save in the bank uh i i want
to both for the previous caller and on
this point
um a lot of people misunderstand what
what is meant by savings most of us we
think of savings as
uh you you put money in a mutual fund
you put money in 401k you put money in
the bank
um and that's uh the way economists
think of it is a little different uh
savings is more of a passive thing
meaning if you have income of 100
and you spend 95 dollars you just saved
five dollars it doesn't matter whether
it's cash in your wallet whether it's in
your bank account
where it is it's more residual based on
what you don't spend
than uh than not so and also for the
caller who's uh who's saying he does pay
his bills and that's his form of savings
well that is savings the way the math
works in economics so if he's paying
down debt
he's uh reducing his his total
indebtedness that shows up in the
statistics of the savings because
uh you know if you were if you owe ten
thousand dollars one one month then the
next month you only own nine thousand
dollars
you've uh improved your your financial
situation by a thousand dollars
how do analysts track that uh the bureau
of economic statistics at the commerce
department uh has a lot of people who do
uh very difficult work trying to to pull
together a lot of data from all over the
economy and
uh it's uh it's not perfect but it's the
best we have we'll go to east petersburg
pennsylvania burley democratic caller go
ahead yes
mike my concern is um a lot of people
have been saying
that you know we bailed wall street but
with everyone's
401k on wall street if we didn't build
wall street we would be in more case
than we're in now
and in terms of the economy and it
getting better
we're looking at domestic spending what
we need to do
is look at everything we need to look at
the money we send overseas and put it
all together and then we need to start
cutting
and reshuffling and if we do that
we're gonna find that people are gonna
be more satisfied
people who who get um voted out in
congress they should go on cobra like
everybody else does
and their retirement should only be
about 10 over what they make
every year when they're in the
government it shouldn't be higher than
that okay we'll leave it there burley
neil irwin uh just a a couple of points
uh
you know the wall street bailouts back
in the fall 2008 and early 2009
um you know they they've had the impact
of of uh helping the stock market come
back
and and you know the market's up a lot
since the low in march of 2009.
um i don't think that was by design i
mean that was that was
obviously an expected side effect but
the main goal of the policymakers who
bailed out all the banks and
and the financial system was trying to
keep the lending and financial system
from breaking down so
the ability of short-term lending to
happen uh the the kind of ability of
money to flow through the system loans
to be made
uh and they largely succeeded in
preventing that from from breaking down
entirely
uh now one benefit of that has been that
the stock market goes up so that has had
some broader benefits than just keeping
the financial system from breaking down
um on on gdp and it's not just
consumption we also have to have uh
investment and uh
the gdp numbers do reflect all that so
consumption is about
two-thirds of of gross domestic product
of overall economic activity but there's
also government spending in there
there's also
business investment goes in there
housing investment and net exports so
things that we import are actually
subtracted from gdp whereas things that
we export are added to it so
uh again economic statistics aren't
perfect but but the one that people use
to chart kind of the overall path of the
economy do capture some of the things
you're mentioning
first republic first tweets in this why
should american people pay their debts
when wall street doesn't
wall street just has the fed print up 32
trillion plus
right uh i mean there's something there
there's a there's a there's a valid
point there i'm not sure it's entirely
fair uh
you know it is true that uh many of the
wall street firms probably would not
have been able to make good on their
debts
had uh had the financial bailout not
happened exactly which firms would have
would have defaulted and collapsed the
way lehman brothers did
uh it's hard to know uh given the
bailouts but uh there's a valid point
there that that the uh
the big banks the big financial firms
essentially had their liabilities
backstopped by the federal government
during the the fall of 2008
uh and uh ordinary americans have not
had the same benefit don a republican in
pittsburgh
morning you're on the air with neil
irwin of the washington post
good morning i don't think the american
public
is extremely well educated in economics
and has a real good grasp of it because
they don't understand the cost of
financing of servicing debt for example
if you pay a thousand dollars for
something and put on a charge card at
twenty percent
over a year you've actually paid twelve
hundred dollars for that
in my parents day in our parents day
they they
always saved up some towards major
purchases to at least offset
you know the payments and keep them
reasonable nowadays everybody has to
have everything
right away right now and they just
finance the full cost of it
and also i would like to know if your
guests could comment on the cost of
servicing the national debt
which is phenomenal what we could do
with that money if we
weren't you know paying the cost of
servicing that 13 trillion we owed thank
you
uh two very good points uh so on the
first one i
i think there is a possibility that that
some people who end up in
in significant credit card debt student
loan debt uh auto loans
mortgages don't fully understand what
they're getting into i think we saw a
lot of that especially in the
2004-2005-2006 period when
uh the debt levels just exploded uh
you know the the the truth is you're
you're exactly right now now credit
cards can have some really good benefits
so if you're
uh you know if you're going along in
your refrigerator breaks or your car
breaks down and you need some short-term
cash to fix it and then you can pay it
off over the next few months
that's a great use of credit cards and a
great way to uh take advantage of that
kind of availability of short-term
credit
uh you know if it's uh somebody's
running a 10 20 30 000
credit card balance and rolling it over
month after month paying it down very
very slowly
uh that's it's less clear what the what
the benefit is there it's uh especially
given the very high rates that there are
in credit cards
uh same with auto loans you know auto
loans can make a lot of sense if you
need that first car and you need to pay
it off but if
you're just kind of perpetually rolling
over debt it's not clear why you do that
instead of saving up
uh so there's a there's a valid point
there that some people especially in the
in the past and to some degree still
are kind of using debt inappropriately
given their financial situation
uh on the on the interest on on the
national debt that's absolutely valid
point and what we're going to see is
what the u.s government pay what
taxpayers have to pay just to
maintain the debt service on our
existing debt is going to be
high and probably rising over the coming
years as the economy gets better
interest rates will rise
that will make that a real burden for
u.s taxpayers donald's a democrat in
dallas texas good morning
good morning my question is
on that report that he made didn't see
anything what it says about the income
level he's telling us that there's
savings and that that
increase is going on but you don't see
what income level
that that's really doing it that's
that's doing the
this that's increasing them paying down
their debt all right let's talk about
that
yeah that's uh that's a valid point i'm
looking at savings rate as a percentage
of income
uh not as a uh absolute level the trend
with income it did decline quite a lot
during the
the the thick of the recession in 2008
2009
uh it has been gradually clawing back
since then it's uh
you know personal income levels are kind
of rising a little bit
uh month by month but nothing to write
home about uh
so you know there's a question of of uh
you know what happens uh will
first of all when will we get real
income increases because that's the
ultimate uh
you know measure of of american
prosperity when will we have real income
increases of a substantial nature and
uh what will happen to to savings levels
and and kind of this
household balance sheet issue once that
day arrives the federal reserve bank of
san francisco studied u.s counties
and how people took on debt relative to
their incomes what did they find what
areas of the country are doing the best
yeah it's interesting what they did is
they took uh u.s counties and divided
them into
counties where there were high debt
levels during the the boom in the
again the mid-2000s uh with uh with
counties where there were very low
levels the top 10 percent of counties
versus the bottom 10 percent
and the economies are doing far better
in in those counties where there was
less debt
so uh if there's any doubt that that
household debt and household this
overhang of household debt is a major
factor in why the economy has been so
weak the last couple years
uh it's very clear that debt levels are
closely correlated with with
uh with weak economic growth and will
the
uh best indicator of our economy uh
recovering
be consumer spending once savings levels
get to a point where they they they uh
they bottom out
are that is that what economists are are
going to be looking at next you know
it's it's no single number uh look the
broadest measure of economic activity is
gdp that captures both consumer spending
and
government spending and business
investment and some other things
that's you know we want that to rise but
that said gdp isn't what we're solving
for as a society
it's nice to have strong gdp but the
reason you want strong gdp is because
usually when there's strong gdp growth
you also have people who have jobs
people have incomes
that's the real goal is that americans
are able to find a job that suits their
skills
and earn a good wage that allows them to
to have a
comfortable existence that's really the
goal of an economic system and the other
things are just ways of kind of
measuring and estimating
that we'll go to annapolis ed on the
independent line go ahead ed
uh first of all thank you for c-span but
secondly
when i retired i set myself up so i had
absolutely no
cuts and i have no debts today
but i i and i reserved my cash
at that time in my home well then i
decided because there's some thefts in
the area that i would move my money into
a bank
well the bank doesn't pay any interest
none at all
and they charge me fees which are in
excess
of the little bit of interest they give
me for the money i have in there
so quite frankly this year i'm going to
move all my money
out of those stupid banks because
they're not doing anything
to me so i think there's a lot of people
like that where are you going to move it
to ed
i'll move it back under my mattress okay
have you thought about gold
if i see a good opportunity then i have
a cash to use to buy it
okay neil irwin um it's true interest
rates are very low that's part of the
policy the federal reserve is pursuing
to try and encourage consumption
encourage investment uh try and get the
economy on track
uh but it's true that uh retirees savers
people who uh
have a large amount of cash they want to
save uh suffers results so it means that
you're
uh not able to to earn the kinds of
interest rates you would normally get
from a bank
uh you know the the reason people
normally don't put cash under a mattress
is because then if your
house gets robbed if if something bad
happens you're in uh
you're out of luck i mean banks for all
their flaws and for the low interest
rates
uh at least you know it's there it's
government guaranteed you know uh the
money's not going away because there's
that fdic backstop
uh so you might want to be cautious
about about uh leaving the banking
system entirely
uh that said the the issue you raise is
exactly right uh
rates are very low that uh that you know
encourages investment and and has
benefits for the economy as a whole
but definitely uh retirees and those
with a big chunk of savings or the
those who suffer as a result let's go to
uh lakeland florida
kino on the republican line good morning
yes good morning and praise be for
c-span uh my question is i'm
i'm real worried about journalists and
economists and
political leaders not factoring in peak
oil and the gas price increases a little
earlier you're talking about the
headline gas may go to five dollars a
gallon
down here in florida our governor new
governor rick scott wants to cancel the
high-speed train
because he doesn't think there's enough
riders well shouldn't there be more
talk and preparation public discussion
and preparation for peak oil going to
these high prices and people won't be
able to afford cars and
where's that being factored in neil
urban can you speak to that
uh it's a it's a valid worry uh
it's hard to know exactly how about what
the probability is what the likelihood
is that
the scenario the caller lays out is
accurate uh
there are some uh widely varying
opinions among oil economist energy
economists those who really study these
things
you know the question is not just uh
supply side of oil you know how much oil
is left in the ground and that's easy to
get to
uh though that is a relevant question
the other question is how rapidly do
china india these other emerging nations
that have huge populations how rapidly
do they become more wealthy do they grow
uh you know there's a there's a billion
people each in in
china and india if uh first of all it's
it's mathematically impossible for them
to get to the levels of of energy
consumption that we're used to here in
the united states
there really isn't enough uh energy in
the ground to enough oil on the ground
to
support that uh that existence um the
question is uh
can there be a path for growth for those
countries as they get wealthier that
uh that that uh you know is more energy
efficient and and uh deals with this
problem
uh regardless there's a there's a
possibility that we'll see this kind of
ongoing rise in energy prices as long as
there's a
strong global growth that's the pattern
we saw on o708 it's the pattern we're
seeing now that the economies
around the world are looking a little
better again so it's a valid concern i
don't have a solution but it's certainly
something to be worried about
neil irwin is our guest he's economics
reporter for the washington post wrote a
piece last week no longer penny wise and
pound foolish americans are saving
the the savings trend is on the uptick
and whittling down debt
on the spending side of this issue the
consumer financial protection bureau
is having a conference today at the
treasury department and the keynote
speaker will be elizabeth warren uh
assistant to the president special
adviser to the secretary of the treasury
for that consumer
consumer financial protection bureau
she's going to be talking about
uh the one year anniversary of the
effective date of the provisions in the
credit card act outlining
the priorities for her agency making
credit card market work better for
consumers so we're going to have live
coverage of that
on c-span 2 starting around 9 00 a.m
eastern time here in about 45 minutes
neil irwin what are your thoughts on
on that what are you expecting to hear
uh from them to
today this is an interesting uh agency
they were created in the dodd-frank act
uh last year the regulatory reform bill
that passed last summer
uh they're they're just getting rolling
i think there's a lot of open questions
about how exactly this
financial protection bureau is going to
work uh you know that they have some
tricky things to to juggle they they
don't want to limit credit availability
to to consumers too much
because they want people to again be
able to use a credit card when they have
a
when their car breaks down and they need
repairs uh so they don't want banks to
stop extending credit entirely
on the other hand there's been a lot of
exploitative practices as a few of our
callers have mentioned you know people
have
been irresponsible with debt the last
few years and sometimes in ways where
the the
credit card companies and the other
kinds of lenders themselves have played
a role
you also don't want to force too many
people into more the black market so
whether it's literally loan sharks or or
you know check cashing places that
charge
you a huge fee or pawn shops you want
people to be able to get access to
credit
but in ways that don't leave them uh
holding the bag and in really bad shape
in the long term so trying to juggle
that will be a
ongoing task this agency as it gets
rolling we'll go to providence
rhode island jack independent caller
hey uh good morning greta good morning
mr whirlwind
uh i have a question for mr irwin
all this saving is great and that's what
we should have been doing a long time
but what happens if the dollar gets
unpacked from the oil
trading and our dollar collapses what
happens to all those savings
uh first of all you know it's it's so if
if the dollar were to
were to decline a lot uh most people
aren't expecting a dollar collapse of
any kind
it is still the the most uh liquid
currency in the world it's still the
currency that people use when they want
to uh
want to to find a safe haven uh that
doesn't seem to be changing
anytime soon but uh if uh if your
scenario were true if the dollar
collapses
uh the main impact on americans is it
would make imports a lot more expensive
so
price of oil would go up a lot the price
of uh foreign cars the price
of uh you know anything you bring in
from abroad uh would would certainly go
up
uh you know domestically for domestic
industries it would have a more
complicated impact it would make u.s
exporters a lot more competitive might
actually lead to job creation and the
kind of export industries that
uh where u.s businesses that aren't very
competitive now suddenly would have an
advantage that they don't
uh so they're they're you know it's not
something anybody wants to see a dollar
collapse would definitely be bad for
world stability for financial stability
cause a lot of dislocation in the
economy uh at the same time it's
something that
uh you know moderate decline actually
might help us with uh
some of our jobs issues and uh and
things on the export side
let's go if if the dollar collapse
what happens to the people's savings
because i see
i see a spike in silver and metals going
up that peop
people are saving but they could be
saving in metals
which that doesn't lose their value
well first of all that's not true uh
metals uh you know gold other precious
metals
uh you know if you bought in the in the
late 70s uh you
uh and then sold in in the late 90s that
was a 20-year period where you lost a
whole lot of money uh
you know investing in gold silver these
things
it can't offer returns but it also comes
at a risk so people shouldn't assume
that's just a free lunch and and
will offer you very stable returns
without without some amount of risk
uh on the general point we'll have
people's savings if the dollar declines
a lot uh
well they would uh go a lot less far in
in
around the world and again for imports a
lot of goods that we import would become
more expensive there's no question about
that
uh in terms of domestic industries there
would be uh you know not
uh not much change if you if you uh are
consuming more non-imported goods there
wouldn't be as much of a difference
we're talking about american savings but
as we do that want to continue to give
you updates on the situation in libya
ap is reporting that governments are
scrambling to get their citizens out of
the country
where there has been a week of bloody
unrest it says thousands of turks have
crowded into a stadium to await
evacuation and egyptians
have been gathering at the border to
escape the chaos let's go to vegas
claire democratic line go ahead hi i
wanted to
say that in regard to oil here in las
vegas
in nevada we are embracing solar power
and that can make up for a lot of
importing oil and also i was wondering
uh mr irwin why you're not
embracing the work of elizabeth warren
who's
out there working darn hard for the
middle class and finally
uh your opinion of um paul krugman
um i think he's a real asset for us oh
and finally suzy orman too
okay a lot there claire all right neil
irwin
uh i'm not uh i'm not i'm not
criticizing elizabeth warren she uh
is is doing a very difficult task of
trying to put together this agency and
and uh uh create an agency that'll
that'll
be a powerful force for uh for for
making america's financial lives better
all i'm saying is there are a number of
trade-offs that this agency will have to
to entertain and juggle as they try and
move forward so i'm not i'm not
criticizing her
and you were saying that there are there
are questions from others on the outside
looking in
at this agency and criticisms well it's
you know they haven't they don't exist
yet they haven't done stuff yet they
haven't introduced regulations
as they do that'll be the question is
how do they try and strike this line
between
uh protecting consumers and making sure
that credit remains available
they had about i believe it was one year
essentially to to get this agency up and
running
right and up and running and then you
know the regulatory process is a slow
one so
introducing actual regulation right now
the action on the regulatory front with
credit cards is at the federal reserve
for example
which is traditionally overseeing these
things momness one tweets in this please
explain the difference between the big
banks and local credit unions
uh i don't know what there is to explain
they uh the the
the big uh the big banks are uh very
large and have branches all over the
world and
uh trillion dollars in assets uh your
local credit union is a non-profit that
uh
you have to be a member some group or
some uh some uh
an employee of some company to be a
member of uh often offer lower fees
lower interest rates uh for for
borrowers higher interest rates for
depositors uh they're not earning uh
because they're not for-profit companies
they don't uh have that uh
segment their their settings high for
profits so a lot of people find it uh
useful and and more pleasant to deal
with the credit union uh there are some
advantages for the big banks they have
bigger pools of capital they have
international you know branches all over
the country so there are some advantages
there too but often higher fees
at a republican in marblehead
massachusetts
yes good morning thank you for c-span
excuse me i think one important factor
that's left out of the discussion
is uh what uh what role the federal
budget deficit has uh in private sector
savings
and to make a long story bearable
the deeper the government goes into debt
uh the easier it is
for the private sector to save and pay
down debt
and an example would be in december
everyone got a
a two percent uh tax cut on their social
security payroll taxes
so workers and employed people now have
extra money in their pocket
which they can choose to either pay down
debt or save
or consume so uh but the treasury had to
issue more debt
in order to cover that shortfall so the
two sides uh are like it's like your
mirror images
the deeper the government goes into debt
um the more
savings uh the private sector has um
on the opposite you know balancing it
out right uh
i i think that's a very important point
and and uh
you know there's even an aspect to which
uh not everybody can deleverage at the
same time just mathematically
one person's uh savings is another
person's investment that's that's uh
that's the goal anyway
and that's what banks and other forms of
credit intermediation do in the economy
is they
they uh take one-person savings and turn
it into another person's investment
uh if nobody was borrowing money then uh
then we would
it would you know be a problem but
because the government has increased
their deficit
that's uh soaked up some of the
deleveraging that's happened by uh by
consumers
uh let's go to grand blank michigan
donald democratic line
up but help if i push the button go
ahead donald
i really think that uh until we get the
country back to uh
to working it's gonna be hard for any
american to be
to save i mean because everything is
going up gas
uh gas prices food
so until we solve that problem and and
get the country uh
saved you know i mean get the country to
work and we're not gonna be able to save
anything
unemployment rate yeah it's uh it's
absolutely true we're at a nine percent
unemployment rate
uh by some broader measures of
unemployment we're still around 17
percent
uh that's enormous and uh you know none
of what i'm saying it should put a gloss
on the fact that we still have a
terrible job market
and uh clawing out of it is the is the
true measure of
of whether the economy's getting back to
where it needs to be
and certainly unemployment is one of the
biggest things uh hanging over
people's household balance sheets
people's personal finances
cape coral florida nelson a republican
you're next from here
for neil irwin go ahead good morning
how are you good morning i do have some
good news
basically uh the financial housing
market model that we have
today is basically probably somewhat
obsolete
and i know they're working on the
problem but the good news is that
every senator and congressman surely
will be receiving a new
uh financial housing model and uh
without having to depend on inflation
if they do decide to review and
implement that
then the savings of america uh without
even regards to inflation
will be restored there will be a new
model to be able to allow them
to go ahead and indeed take advantage of
you know their housing
as being a tool to work for them and
spread against
the way it's currently set up neil irwin
i think the college referring to
efforts to reform the housing finance
system fannie mae and freddie mac were
the government sponsored
housing companies that mortgage
companies that were bailed out back in
the fall of 2008
they've kind of been limping along but
actually accounting for a huge
percentage of mortgage lending right now
because private lenders
uh just were away from the party and not
participating and not really making
mortgage loans uh through this last
couple of years that's starting to
change some
you know so the question is can a more
sustainable housing finance system which
the obama administration has offered
three proposals
republicans are starting to to offer
their own ideas
can a reformed housing finance system be
better for the economy in the long run
and help on
on some of these savings and financial
issues uh one point
you know one idea that's being tossed
around a lot is having minimum down
payment requirements
maybe 10 maybe 15 maybe 20 no more of
this
you know people putting three percent
down five percent down uh and buying a
house
uh you know i'm not sure how directly
connected it is to the
to the current savings issue but in the
long run uh having a fina a financial
system that
supports mortgage lending but does so in
a way that a doesn't cost taxpayers a
lot of money and b
uh you know doesn't create a bunch of
distorted incentives for people to
to run up the prices of homes would uh
would be a good thing
kevin a democrat in woodbridge virginia
good morning
yes how you doing today doing well sir
my question is
i can understand why the caller called
in a concern and putting the money up on
this mattress
my wife and i believe in savings let's
say we put ten thousand dollars in the
bank at
five percent interest and at the end of
the year we have a thousand dollars uh
in interest
why is it that we have to give the
government a
a portion of that as income
uh well because you made money uh the
government charges income taxes that's
what pays for the government
and uh you know you know to ask the
question a different way
why would somebody who makes a thousand
dollars working in a factory have to pay
taxes but somebody makes a thousand
dollars in interest income not have to
pay taxes that would be kind of unfair
to people who earn their money from
labor as opposed to from savings so
that's why the government uh charges
income taxes on
on investment income as well as on on
labor income
a couple more phone calls here shepard
and independent in florida morning
good morning c-span uh one of the things
i'd like to point out is many americans
uh
don't know how to manage money
i've been working since i was 16 years
old and i've noticed a lot of people
they'll buy that cup of coffee in the
morning they'll buy their lunch from a
lunch wagon or a fast food restaurant
for years i've been the type of person
who packs his own lunch
i was the type of person who would deny
myself things i was the type of person
who bought store brands
and yet i see people who know nothing
about using coupons they know nothing
about mail-in rebates
i mean i'm the type of person i could
have afforded to buy an expensive car
and i've stuck with low-cost entry-level
economy cars
another point i'd like to make out as
americans are becoming less and less
dependent on themselves
i have an advantage i can do most of my
home and auto repairs
and when i try to educate people on how
to do things
they just throw their hands up and say
oh please i wouldn't even know
which way to turn the screwdriver i'm
not talking about being able to overhaul
your engine
just be able to perform basic
maintenance okay and yet
all right shepard we'll leave it there
neil irwin um
look if you look at the numbers if you
look at the the amount of debt that
people took out in the in the mid 2000s
uh up until a low seven or 008 really uh
you know obviously some people knew what
they do they were doing uh it's pretty
clear a lot of people were getting in
over their heads in ways that
uh maybe they didn't fully understand uh
you know it's
there's a lot of blame to go around in
this thing and and i think people do
have to look inward and say what should
my uh
decisions be on saving and spending and
what can i actually afford and
and make decisions accordingly same time
uh you know there were some banks making
some some
pretty crummy loans that they shouldn't
have made and we're extending credit to
people who
really shouldn't have been receiving it
so uh but i think the basic point that
that
you know plenty of people have been
living by beyond their means is
absolutely true and that's something
that people have to take their own
responsibility for
deal with one last phone call here for
you nancy a democrat in panama city
florida you're on the air
hi i have one question although i do
agree with the last caller
on uh on
what we do for ourselves but my big
question in listening to all this
economic stuff
is my understanding
is that when the banks foreclose on a
piece of property
and are holding the real estate owned
type thing
they don't pay taxes on those property
and then when you buy a piece of
foreclosed property
you have to pay back taxes how much
money do you think we'd have
now if the banks would pay the taxes on
their real estate
neil irwin does she have it right i
think they're supposed to pay taxes on
the real estate i'm sure there are
plenty of cases where they don't and
their liens attached to the property and
then whoever buys it subsequently is
is on the hook uh you know this is one
of the one of the kind of
structural issues of why the foreclosure
problem is such a deep crisis because
foreclosed houses uh there might be
liens from the property taxes if the
bank wasn't paying the
bills or if the previous tenant wasn't
paying or previous owner wasn't paying
the property tax bills
uh you know there's often uh there's
crime there's there's vandalism there's
uh problems with these houses so uh you
know one of the reasons uh the
foreclosure crisis has been so bad is
because there are all these kind of
follow-on effects that
uh that cause broader damage and that's
why we'll all be happy when uh when the
rate of foreclosures finally gets down
to a
to a more normal level neil irwin what
will you be watching for this week in
as far as the economy uh we uh there's
there's there's a trickle of data
nothing uh
nothing huge but uh uh trying to think
of anything
there's always the thursday uh weekly
claims report but uh no no major
releases this week to read more of neil
irwin's writing go to washingtonpost.com
he's the economics reporter there thank
you very much for your time
appreciate it in our last uh 45 minutes
this morning around 9 15
a.m eastern time we're going to turn our
attention to the internet and u.s
foreign policy but first coming up bill
gertz of the washington times
geopolitical editor will be here to talk
about unrest
in the middle east here's a news update
from c-span radio
it's half past the hour hungary's
foreign minister who is currently the
chair of the european union
is telling israel that growing
instability in the middle east
makes it imperative to immediately
resume the stalled peace process
with the palestinians he went on to say
that time is pressing
and that the israeli-palestinian talks
remain the core
issue israeli-palestinian peace talks
collapsed just weeks after they
restarted in september
because israel ended a 10-month
moratorium on settlement construction
meanwhile israel's defense ministry in a
statement today
says israel and the united states have
carried out a successful test
of the arrow anti-missile system off the
coast of california
the missile detected intercepted and
destroyed a target missile
launched yesterday from an offshore
platform inside a u.s navy firing range
the exercise is the latest in a series
of successful tests of the system
that the israeli defense ministry says
provides confidence and
operational capabilities to defeat the
developing ballistic missile
threat and it's tax season and the new
york daily news is reporting today that
congressman charlie rangel
is offering tax annual tax tips in a
recent email to his constituents
the congressman has included what he
calls the wrangle report
and it features tax advice charlie
rangel was recently found guilty by his
colleagues in the house of
representatives
of multiple ethics violations including
the failure to pay taxes on his
dominican villa
and those are some of the latest
headlines on c-span radio
you're watching c-span bringing you
politics and public affairs